[Música]
río de janeiro la segunda ciudad más
grande de brasil adoptará nuevas
restricciones para contener el avance de
la pandemia de kobe 19 en un intento por
frenar la ola de muertes y contagios de
varios estados también que extremas
medidas mientras tanto el presidente ya
ir bolsonaro volvió a minimizar la
emergencia tenemos reporte
la alta comisionada para los derechos
humanos de la onu michelle bachelet
informó que desde el primero de febrero
cuando se dio el golpe militar en
myanmar al menos 54 personas murieron
por la represión policial y cerca de
1700 fueron detenidas la casa blanca
condenó la violencia y prometió acciones
grupos paramilitares de irlanda del
norte anunciaron que se van a retirar
temporalmente su respaldo al histórico
acuerdo de paz de viernes santo firmado
en 1998 que establece la frontera entre
la provincia británica y el resto de
reino unido el anuncio se da en medio de
preocupaciones sobre un factor praxis en
el comercio interno
muy buenas noches gracias por continuar
con nosotros en france 24 si revelan con
gusto saludarlos comenzamos a este
informativo en brásil
río de janeiro la segunda ciudad más
grande de ese país adoptarán nuevas
restricciones para contener el avance
del coi 19 en la nación hoy se
registraron mil 699 muertes lo que eleva
el número total a 260 1970 la ciudad de
6.7 millones de habitantes se impondrá
un toque de queda nocturno y el cierre
de cualquier tipo de actividad comercial
en sus playas durante una semana entre
otras medidas las nuevas restricciones
entrarán en vigor este viernes y hasta
el 11 de marzo aunque podrían
prorrogarse si la crisis continúa salió
en este momento a nuestra corresponsal
valeria saccone valeria la saludo muy
buena noche que más se conoce sobre
estas nuevas restricciones en río de
janeiro y en otros estados del país
sabemos que van a cerrar bares y
restaurantes a partir de las 5 de la
tarde que no se puede circular durante
la noche que están prohibidas todo tipo
de fiesta y de espectáculo musical y que
sí se podrá ir a la playa pero sin
comercio ambulante que es una
característica de las playas urbanas de
río de janeiro lo que hay que ver es si
los cariocas serán capaces de respetar
una semana de restricciones porque en
esas semanas hemos visto una ciudad
abarrotada de gente donde si alguien
llegase sin saber nada pensaría que no
hay una pandemia además hay varios
estados del país que están haciendo lo
mismo entre ellos hablamos ayer de san
paolo pero también para nada bahía santa
catarina que es uno de los estados más
golpeados hay que recordar que brasil
sigue sin una política nacional de
coordinación de lucha contra la pandemia
y que el presidente llegue bolsonaro se
opone al okda nacional
hablando de eso valeria cuál ha sido la
reacción del presidente de visionario
quien rechaza todo tipo de medidas de
contención para el avance de esta
pandemia
podemos decir que el discurso de bolsa
narón no ha cambiado a lo largo de un
año hoy ha vuelto a defender la economía
y lo hace la misma semana en que sabemos
que el pib el año pasado cayó a un 41
por ciento es el peor dato de los
últimos 30 años aunque es mejor de lo
que se esperaba ahora bien hoy bolsonaro
ha dado más declaraciones cuando menos
polémicas diciendo que los brasileños
tienen que parar de lloriquear y de
quejarse y ha minimizado de nuevo el
efecto de la pandemia y ha dicho que el
desempleo tiene que ser enfrentado ahora
así como las consecuencias económicas de
esta pandemia
valeria gracias por la información que
tengo usted un feliz resto de noche
nosotros continuamos seguimos con el
violento escenario político y social que
vive mi hermano hoy la alta comisionada
para los derechos humanos de la onu
michelle bachelet dijo que desde el
primero de febrero cuando se dio el
golpe militar al menos 54 personas
murieron por la represión policial
además cerca de 1700 fueron detenidas
durante las masivas manifestaciones
entre ellas 29 periodistas marina
sardiña nos trae una aproximación al
contexto
detrás de los militares golpistas
quién está detrás del golpe de estado
militar y la brutal represión posterior
el ejército está armado como se conoce
localmente a las fuerzas armadas
birmanas bajo el liderazgo del general
min lo llevó a cabo lo que podría
denominarse como un autogolpe parcial
puesto que gozaban de un amplio poder y
una autonomía total durante el mandato
de la líder de puesta al sub si la
constitución birmana otorga al ejército
el control sobre tres ministerios de
seguridad clave y el 25 por ciento de
los escaños en el parlamento pertenecen
a soldados elegidos por el comandante
jefe porque los generales se arriesgan a
desmantelar un sistema construido a su
medida recapitulando en la historia de
mianmar
este es el tercer golpe de
estado-militar tras la independencia de
los colonos británicos en 1948 en 1962
el general ne win de un golpe e impuso
la vía birmana al socialismo que marcó
el inicio del gobierno de partido único
y el dominio político autoritario del
ejército que se extendió durante 49 años
en 1988 los birmanos se rebelaron contra
el régimen la represión de las fuerzas
de seguridad dejó más de 3.000 muertos
ni win dimitió y dio comienzo la
dictadura de la junta
que abandonó el socialismo y se volvió
aún más represiva liderando mianmar
durante casi seis décadas con la misión
histórica de preservar la unidad de una
nación donde existen decenas de grupos
étnicos y más de una veintena de grupos
armados en 2015 los comicios dieron la
victoria al partido de such y la liga
nacional para la democracia quien
gobernó tratando de ganarse la confianza
del ejército sushi y hablaba de
reconciliación nacional mientras negaba
las atrocidades de los militares y no
hacía nada para retener su guerra contra
las minorías étnicas el tan malo uno de
los sistemas de poder más opacos del
mundo ha sobrevivido a más de medio
siglo de asedio por las duras sanciones
impuestas por la comunidad internacional
y ahora es más bien la resistencia del
movimiento civil birmano que continúa
saliendo a las calles de todo el país
quien puede lograr la instauración de un
sistema democrático que pasa por revisar
el indiferente papel de hans and shoots
y para efectuar un cambio significativo
en el mar
y continuamos con más noticias aumentan
las tensiones entre la unión europea
reino unido e irlanda del norte
paramilitares se retiraron de los
acuerdos de paz de 1998 por el protocolo
irlanda del norte que establece la
frontera entre la provincia británica y
el resto del reino unido una condición
que impuso la unión europea para lograr
el acuerdo del proxy
el primer ministro británico boris
johnson decidió unilateralmente extender
hasta octubre la entrada efectiva y
total de la aduana algo que no ha
gustado a ninguna de las partes nos
informa dos mundos
un divorcio siempre deja secuelas es lo
que está sucediendo con el break sit
concretamente en irlanda del norte donde
paramilitares unionistas británicos
levantaron su apoyo a los acuerdos del
viernes santo de 1998 que pusieron fin a
una sangrienta guerra de tres décadas lo
hicieron mediante un comunicado si
vosotros el reino unido no estáis
preparados para honrar la totalidad del
acuerdo entonces seréis responsables de
la permanente destrucción del acuerdo el
acuerdo deber existe establecía en el
protocolo de irlanda del norte que la
aduana fronteriza estará fijada en los
puertos de belfast y land de esta forma
se evita que haya una frontera física
entre irlanda y la provincia de reino
unido irlanda del norte
uno de los principales logros de los
acuerdos de paz de 1998 sin embargo el
break si está revivido viejos fantasmas
y la aduana dentro del reino unido entre
islas está provocando escasez de
productos y malestar entre los sectores
protestantes y unionistas piden que se
revoque por completo al protocolo de
irlanda del norte y no tener fronteras
con reino unido sin embargo sin este
protocolo la unión europea no hubiera
permitido
de forma que en la práctica irlanda del
norte continuará formando a largo plazo
parte del mercado comunitario en este
contexto el primer ministro británico
boris johnson trata de prorrogar
unilateralmente hasta octubre el período
de gracia acordado con bruselas
esto significa que reino unido está
extendiendo la entrada en vigor de los
controles aduaneros y sanitarios
definitivos
estoy seguro que con un poco de buena
voluntad y sentido común todos estos
problemas técnicos son eminentemente
solucionables hollywood
sin embargo la unión europea' ha
mostrado su modestia y aseguran que
reinó unido- está violando la ley
internacional ya que el acuerdo
establecía que en junio como muy tarde
debía comenzar la frontera aduanera
virtual y totalmente efectiva entre el
reino unido e irlanda del norte
el servicio geológico de eeuu detectó un
sismo de magnitud 8.1 en la escala de
richter al norte de nueva zelanda lo que
motivó que el centro de alertas de
tsunamis del pacífico emitiera un aviso
por maremoto que afecte a las islas de
hawai el terremoto tuvo una profundidad
de 19 kilómetros y fue precedido de
temblores de intensidad menor
previamente en la misma zona se registró
otro movimiento de tierra de magnitud
7.3 que sacudió en la madrugada del
viernes las aguas al noreste de nueva
zelanda lo que produjo una alerta de
tsunami inicial que luego fue retirada
i
y de esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo en france24 continúa con
nosotros para más actualizaciones de
noticia feliz noche y hasta pronto
[Música]
siga todas las noticias del deporte con
france24 todas las imágenes todas las
reacciones todos los resultados